China has warned they're being pushed
closer to Russia because of the
hostility shown by the United States in
a press conference the new Chinese
foreign minister warned of conflict if
the U.S doesn't change its path last
month U.S Secretary of State Anthony
blinken said there'd be consequences if
China supplied weapons to Russia to help
in their invasion of Ukraine well Mr
Chin denied arms had been sent to Moscow
well I'm joined Now by a military
analyst retired of ice Marshal Sean Bell
and shown strong words from the Chinese
foreign minister what's your take on
these comments it's always a worry when
a major superpower starts talking about
likely conflicts if America continues to
push and apply pressure to China the US
has been pretty tough with China of late
particularly trying to stop China
supplying weapons to Russia it's also
about Chinese position on Taiwan and
most recently obviously the Spy balloon
Scandal when China was floating
allegedly meteorological balloons over
China now these comments were made in
press conference it is worth pointing
out the Chinese press conferences are
not the same as they are across the West
they're all pre-agreed questions the
answers are all scripted and therefore
it's all very clear messaging but on
face value they did appear that the
China's felt they were being pushed more
to supporting Russia but the harsh
reality of this is China needs access to
the global markets it does not actually
want to revoke a cold war with America
and most likely it would prefer to sit
on the fence throughout all of this and
indeed be seen as The Peacemaker
throughout it so what's most likely when
you read between the lines of this these
harsh words it's almost certainly saying
to America Don't Force China to take
sides in the Ukraine Russia War what
about what's actually happening on the
ground though around back much what's
the latest there
the fighting is continuing all along the
front as ferociously but as we've been
regularly updating the situation in
batmooch was getting critical and the
Ukrainian position was getting quite
precarious they do seem to have
stabilize their lines now although um
the Russians have actually blown a
bridge one of the key access routes out
to the West which Ukraine was using for
resupply and of course with the muddy
conditions that makes it really
difficult for Ukraine to do their
resupply but the real issue here is
whether Ukraine fights for back moot or
withdraws we'll remember that the U.S
defense secretary Lloyd Austin talked
about withdrawal not being a strategic
backward step if they did that and that
was really because the U.S military felt
that it was almost certainly more
prudent to withdraw precious assets out
of bathmoud rather and to live and fight
another day but of course president
zelenski has actually made the order to
reinforce bakamut rather than actually
withdraw and that's almost certainly
because he owns these lands he knows
he's going to have to fight Russia if
not in back moot then where and also
just despite the devastation as we can
see here from at the back move if you
give it up it's going to be even more
difficult to take it back but from a
strategic perspective I think what's
increasingly apparent with a really slow
progress of Russia is Russia is not
going to achieve its strategic objective
of taking hold of the donbass without
having a major mobilization not just to
people its economy and its industry all
that will take time which they don't
have at the moment and what about
reports of this new weapon that Russia's
using tell us a little bit more about
that yeah we don't often see a new
Russian weapon it's um the 2000 pound
Bond the u-pad 1500 v a catchy acronym
it's at first used a few weeks ago it's
a two thousand pound class weapon it is
not powered so it's a gliding weapon the
higher you deliver it the further it
goes if you deliver from 45 000 feet
it'll go about 40 kilometers it's got
some sort of inertia navigation system
probably GPS guided as well at the front
the challenge is is with any air
delivered weapon you've got to get
relatively close to the Target and
you've got to be relatively high that
means you You're vulnerable to the
enemy's air defense system so Ukraine
actually claimed it successfully shot
down one of these the su-20 su-34
fullback just the other day that was
carrying one of these weapons and was
very very vulnerable so um useful weapon
or whether it's going to make a material
impact I doubt it Sean thanks very much